ja also die uhr hat ja nachdem russland
die ukraine überfallen hat riesiges
aktionspakete auf den weg gebracht und
das ausdrückliche ziel dieser sanktionen
war putin unter druck zu setzen seien
verbrecherischen krieg zu beenden und
ich finde langsam ist es zeit der
wahrheit ins gesicht zu sehen und
festzustellen diese sanktionspolitik ist
leider komplett gescheitert sie hat
dieses ziel nicht nur nicht erfüllt
sondern sie wirkten in die andere
richtung sie ruiniert uns nicht russland
wir haben einen rekord inflation viele
leute wissen nicht mehr wie sie das
lebensnotwendige bezahlen sollen es gibt
prognosen sollte der gasfluss jetzt im
juli ganz ausbleiben dass die deutsche
wirtschaft im zweiten halbjahr um zwölf
prozent einbricht das über fünf
millionen industriearbeitsplätze bedroht
sind in einem halben jahr das hin
zustände wie in der weimarer republik
und selbst wenn es nicht zu diesem
allerschlimmsten kommt ganz viele
betriebe denken ja jetzt schon darüber
nach nach einer umfrage jeder fünfte
dass die betriebsteile arbeitsplätze ins
ausland verlagern weil es einfach in
deutschland bei den renten energiekosten
nicht mehr wirtschaftlich ist zu
produzieren so und was ist in russland
die russische wirtschaft funktioniert
halbwegs normal das heißt die inflation
hat sich gerade wieder geht gerade
wieder etwas runter das leben scheint
weitgehend normal zu sein die supermarkt
regale sind gefüllt die straßen sind
voller staus und vor allem die
russischen einnahmen also der
staatshaushalt den man eigentlich
treffen wollte die sind höher ist je
zuvor weil die hohen preise natürlich
obwohl man weniger verkauft letztlich
bei putin mit zusätzlichen einnahmen zu
buche schlagen und ich muss ja wenn man
das konstatiert dann kann man doch nicht
sagen wir machen so weiter und auch das
ganze gerede über alternative
lieferanten für öl für gas das war doch
heiße luft wir haben keine alternativen
lieferanten wir haben sie bei öl nicht
und wir haben sie kurzfristig auch bei
gas nicht das hat sich alles zerschlagen
was habe ich dann vorgeschlagen hat oder
was habe ich in aussicht gestellt hat
und deswegen finde ich muss man in der
situation ganz klar sagen dieser
wirtschaftskrieg ist gescheitert wir
sollten die sanktionen aufheben wenn wir
keine anderen lieferanten haben dann
bitteschön kaufen wir russisches öl und
gas so viel wie wir halt brauchen für
unsere wirtschaft wir treiben mit vielen
ländern handel die kriege führen die die
menschenrechte missachten und mit füßen
treten zum beispiel in den golfstaaten
wo also homosexuelle hingerichtet werden
frauen gesteinigt werden wenn wir mit
allen ländern unseren handel unterbinden
wollten die sich nicht so verhalten wie
wir oder wie wir uns das wünschen ja
dann werden wir müssen wir also mehr
oder weniger unseren handel auf die
europäische union beschränken oder
selbst da wo es teilweise schwierig also
insoweit finde ich es ist eine völlig
falsche politik ich finde es
verantwortungslos dass die regierung
diesen weg weitergeht und mit
irgendwelchen wohl fallen
energiespartipps aufwartet stadt das
problem an der wurzel zu lösen wir
bräuchten keinen notstand zu haben wir
könnten die energie beziehen die wir
brauchen und ich finde wir sollten das
wirklich tun das ist die regierung
eigentlich das hat sie mit ihrem amtseid
geschworen nämlich schaden vom deutschen
volk abzuwenden
das soll sie jetzt bitte einlösen
schluss mit den sanktionen und kaufen
wir die energie die wir brauchen damit
wir wieder normal eben keine frage und
putin gehen wir hin und sagen okay wir
machen das diplomatische schröder hat
das probiert er wird sich nicht aus
dieser ukraine zurückziehen er sich sein
ziel
wenn er sogar mehr aber dadurch aber
dann haben sie eine bessere idee er
lacht sein tribut über uns ja wir haben
eine bessere idee ja wir haben eine sehr
gute idee wir müssen das allerwichtigste
ist dass wir darüber nachdenken was ist
für die ukrainischen bürger das beste
wie können wir den ukrainern am besten
helfen genau und da gehen die meinungen
natürlich auseinander denn der deutsche
idealismus sagt
gerechtigkeit wir müssen den ukrainern
soviel waffen wie möglich geben damit
sie sich gegen die bösen russen
verteidigen können aber das wissen wir
als mütter wenn wir streiten die kinder
haben dass wir die streitenden die netze
erstmal auseinander nehmen müssen und
dann müssen wir verhandeln oder sagt er
hat angefangen und so ist es bei großen
leuten auch das heißt würden würden sie
putin und die ukraine mit streiten
kindern vergleichen also jeder streit
zwischen erwachsenen zwischen völkern
alles was auf der welt passiert können
sie im miniatur in einer familie
beobachten das ist also die marco di
marco sicht und ich denke immer wie
könnte man denn der ukraine am besten
helfen und ich habe von anfang an gesagt
deutschland sie sehen punkten aber auch
als den angreifer wie im bösen bruder
der dem anderen einfach eine rein haut
oder so etwas gemacht hat genau aber ich
sage das interessiert mich gar nicht
mich interessiert das ukrainische volk
und ich möchte dass das ukrainische volk
das land nicht zerstört wird wir dürfen
eine sache nicht vergessen die
amerikanische militärdoktrin ist nach
wie vor die der flexible response und
das habe ich aus diesem fantastischen
buch von klaus von dohnanyi der nämlich
dass das mit dem titel nationale
interessen und diese flexible response
bedeutet dass die verteidigung und das
kriegsgeschehen immer in dem land des
opfers stattfindet also das angegriffene
land und dass man dieses angegriffene
land womöglich bis zu seiner zerstörung
dass man die zerstörung
in kauf nehmen muss hawaii ist flexible
response das ist militärdoktrin der
amerikaner wissen gerade ich bin ein
großer anhänger ihres pragmatismus aber
auch leutnant der reserve wie
wahrscheinlich viele aus ihrem
freundeskreis ebenso
insofern weiß ich auch was flexible
response und wahrscheinlich hat klaus
von dohnanyi das so aufgeschrieben
flexible response bedeutet eigentlich
dass man auf eine eine
reine gegen eine 1 nicht nur drogen
sondern eine vision ein kriegsakt des
gegners flexibler reagiert das heißt man
kann sogar wenn auf die nukleare ebene
geht mit taktischen oder mit
mittelstreckenraketen damals war das so
oder mit strategische nuklearraketen
antwort also dieses diesel diese form
auf eine bedrohung oder auf einen
angriff mit einem nicht nur angemessen
sondern einem eskalierenden mittel oder
mit einem anderen mittel antworten zu
können das ist eigentlich bisher nicht
aber im land des angegriffenen statt das
findet im land des opfers opfer die
flexible response findet in der ukraine
statt und deswegen sage ich wäre mein
plädoyer
diese
waffenlieferungen vor allen dingen das
was die eben heilige friedenspartei die
grünen die haben am lautesten gefordert
schweres gerät in die ukraine aber damit
schaden wir doch den ukrainern denn
solange der krieg angeheizt wird mit
mehr waffen wird es niemals zur ruhe
kommen aber all das ist doch überhaupt
gar kein ich meine wollen sie hingehen
und diplomatisch das wurde doch alles
versucht es wurde er mehrfach wurden ja
politiker haben es versucht mit putin
dass irgendwie zu regeln obwohl sie
selber in die ukraine gehen und sagen
okay wir helfen aber
als als männer freund als auch nicht als
schuldige laut honda männer freund von
herrn putin normalerweise sagt man immer
diese männer auf kameradschaft das
bewirkt was über satz bedeckt sie
glauben ja nicht ernsthaft wirklich
nicht ernsthaft dass das dass wir da
irgendetwas ausrichten können indem wir
da hingehen und und sage jetzt jetzt sag
mal friedlich miteinander wie man das
mit kindern meinen wir nicht ich glaube
dass wir schon was ausrichten könnten
also wie er heißt jetzt eigentlich vor
allem die vereinigten staaten der west
also oder der westen insgesamt ich meine
ich fand interessant vor kurzem ist ja
hat das editorial board der new york
times einen sehr guten artikel
geschrieben und sie haben beiden dafür
kritisiert dass er im grunde die ukraine
geradezu verdonnert hat nicht
kompromissbereit zu sein und sie haben
dort gesagt wenn wir diesen kurs weiter
fahren also wenn die us regierung diesen
kurs weiterfährt dann riskieren sie eine
unglaubliche eskalation bis hin eben
auch zur ausweitung des krieges auf ganz
europa und es müsste jetzt endlich mal
muss sich von unrealistischen kriegs
zielen verabschieden und ähnlich hat
sich kissinger auch geäußert in davos
also es gibt ja schon immer mehr stimmen
und ich glaube das sind aber jetzt
wieder ein ganz großes interview auch
gegeben und da hat accenture
beispielsweise gesagt gehabt das ist
natürlich die territorien da hat er sich
in davos auf missverstanden gefühlt wohl
dass die territorien die zur ukraine
gehört haben inklusive der krim sollten
auch zurück an die ukraine und dass er
schon auch für die sanktionen ist aber
muss den korridor aufhalten weil kissen
ja auch sagt wo es europa kann sich
nicht ohne russland vorstellen ist weil
immer ein wichtiger partner und die
frage ist ja auch jahre dass sie jetzt
nicht also dass man jetzt nicht sagt die
gehören zu russland okay aber man muss
sie erst einmal ausklammern also weil es
ist ja nicht realistisch dass sie zurück
erobert werden militärisch sondern wir
haben jetzt eigentlich nur die wahl dass
das alles ungerecht ist ist überhaupt
keine frage aber die frage ist ja was
was will man was will man will man jetzt
einen jahrelang stellungskrieg wo jeden
tag menschen sterben wo eine stadt nach
der nächsten zerstört wird oder hat man
zunächst mal ein korridor die hatten ja
schon mal verhandelt sie waren auch
relativ weit und da haben nicht die
russen sich zurückgezogen das waren ja
diese istanbuler verhandlungen sondern
da hat sie lenski sich zurückgezogen
also ist man bereit zu sagen wir
klammern das erst mal aus wir machen ein
waffenstillstand letztlich war ein
konflikt immer die frage der
nato-mitgliedschaft wir machen da
kompromisse und versuchen dann
langfristig irgendwie einen gemeinsamen
korridor zu finden sei es dass die auch
einfach die bevölkerung dort gefragt
wird diese abstimmen was sie möchte oder
so das sind ja alles wege aber dafür
müssen erst mal die waffen schweigen und
ich glaube diese bereitschaft muss man
haben werden wenn man jetzt sagt also
wir kämpfen bis wir alles zurückerobert
haben dann wird dieser krieg ewig weiter
wichtig wie interessiert das wirklich wo
sehen sie bei dem ein beispiel wo sehen
sie aktuell die kompromissbereitschaft
bei wladimir putin wissen sie nämlich
dass mich gewundert als schröder
hingereist ist habe ich gedacht okay
putin martin ja der wirt ihn jetzt in
menschlichen korridor neben zumindest
damit schröder jetzt nicht als
kompletter versager zurück und sein land
muss die ballen sind freunde und putin
hat jetzt auch die chance sich
kompromissbereit zu zeigen ist nichts
passiert und da habe ich schon gedacht
okay er gibt ihm nicht mal einen
menschlichen körper oder irgendwas
möglichkeit gewesen und ich frage mich
halt ab und an schon wie wir überhaupt
davon ausgehen können dass putin
kompromissbereit ist oder dass er
wirklich nicht weitergehen will als die
ukraine es gibt ja auch experten die
davon ausgehen dass putin nicht schluss
machen wird mit der nahrung woher wird
auch wieder die ukraine jetzt verlassen
sondern es geht darum dass wir ja erst
dann austesten können wie
kompromissbereit putin ist wenn wir
selber kompromissbereit sind also wenn
man in eine solche verhandlung reingeht
mit einem kompromissangebot erst dann
wissen wir wie weit die russen dann auch
wieder einen des controllings angebot
aussehen sollen wir jetzt sagen okay ihr
kriegt diesen korridor dann dann bauen
wir ihm auch wieder alles auf was total
schön zerstört hat sind ja jetzt schon
die verhandlungen und dann hat er
praktisch an land in der ukraine also
mir kommt es so vor als würden hier gab
und danach erkennen dass der donbass
jetzt irgendwie zu russland gehören
sollen es geht darum die gebiete
auszuklammern das war das was man damals
in istanbul verhandelt habe ausklammern
bedeutet auch sagen wir der status
dieser gebiete bleibt offen aber die
ukraine macht zum beispiel das angebot
nato-mitgliedschaft darauf verzichten
wir das war ja immer der streit apfel
das war jetzt der song minsk 192 arena
sowie eine art minsker abkommen so und
man fragt am ende die menschen selber
das kann man ja auch und zwar
international beaufsichtigt also die
referenten die es bisher gab die gab es
ja die waren natürlich nie unter
internationaler aufsicht wenn man die
leute fragt und das wird beaufsichtigt
wäre das ja auch ein durchaus
nachvollziehbares resultat und ich finde
ja nur der ausgangspunkt worüber wir
geredet haben waren ja die sanktionen
und ich glaube egal wie dieser krieg
weitergeht eines muss man doch
konstatieren die sanktionen ändern an
dem krieg nichts da die sanktionen
setzen putin auch nicht unter druck oder
oder unter zugzwang im gegenteil also
wie gesagt sie haben die einnahmen von
russland erhöht das heißt die sanktionen
sind auf jeden fall kein mittel das ist
finde ich erst einmal festival auch
andere andere stimmen und auch andere
experten wie beispielsweise auch sagen
die sanktionen müssen länger wirken und
zum beispiel beispielsweise der
ausschluss aus dem bankensystem der hat
schon auch wirkung gezeigt das problem
ist wohl hat mir auch ein experte gesagt
gab putin interessiert es nicht wie es
im normalen bürger wird in russland auf
jeden fall ist das von manchen die
meinung und um ihn ruhen ist es noch
nicht angekommen also ich habe auch von
normalen bürgern also ich kenne
persönlich also leute die da familie
haben und die haben mir gesagt das leben
des relativ normal also natürlich ist
sind die lebensmittel teurer geworden
sind überall auf der welt teurer
geworden die gehobene mittelschicht die
früher mehr reisen konnte nach europa
die kann das nicht mehr aber der
einfache
normale bürger der konnte sowieso nicht
reisen das heißt für den hat sich
relativ wenig verändert und die
wirtschaft läuft nach wie vor halbwegs
rund also es ist nicht so spürbar und je
länger die zeit vergeht also ich halte
das für eine völlige illusion dass die
dass die sanktionen wirken desto länger
hat ja auch putin zeit sich umzustellen
und es ist ja so man hat uns immer
erzählt russland sei international
isoliert das stimmt nicht der größte
teil der welt beteiligt sich nicht an
den sanktionen und deswegen kann
russland seine energie vor allem auch
sein öl seine kohle ganz ohne probleme
in andere regionen der grauen bei regen
und teilweise machen wir ja eine idiotie
also welche russisches öl geht jetzt
massiv nach indien wird in indien
verarbeitet und geht dann natürlich viel
viel teurer zurück nach europa das heißt
wir kaufen jetzt ist das zu diesel
verarbeitete russische öl aus indien
zahlen dafür einen horrenden preis weil
wir ja nicht das russische öl aus
russland kaufen wollen völlig verrückt
oder es werden teilweise natürlich auch
leitungen undeklariert also schiffe auf
hoher see halten den radar aus
deklarieren die ladung transportieren
mit allen letzteres ist allerdings
sanktioniert wurden haben sich diese
frachter irgendwo von mehr getrunken
haben
wir wieder zurück in die familie diese
aktion ist die mutti bestraft die kinder
und jetzt hört man auch da wieder die
psychologie bringen diese strafen was
die kinder wollen drogen nehmen wenn ich
die jetzt bestrafe und einsperren und
fernsehverbot sich das macht natürlich
noch mehr so viel besser ist man spricht
mit ihnen vielleicht können wir doch auf
eine therapie zu sprechen ich will damit
nur sagen sanktionen sind das falsche
mittel das sehen wir in iran das sieht
man übrigens auch in vielen anderen
ländern die in sanktioniert wurden über
jahrzehnte nehmen sie kuba
das ist absolutes falsche mittel ich
finde wir sollten noch einmal das
ukrainische volk in den vordergrund
rücken und fragen ist es richtig dass
wir einen krieg des westens gegen
russland auf ukrainischem boden mit
ukrainischen soldaten die für uns
kämpfen damit wir den russen in die knie
zwingen ist das richtig und wollen wir
dass die russen sind unsere kulturell
unserem brüder ich kann als aristokratin
sagen meine mutter meine großmutter ist
eine russische großfürstin ich habe in
der familie viele verwandte das haus
hessen wir haben unsere prinzessinnen
nach russland geschickt die dort die
zarin katharina die große ist eine
anhalt-zerbst wir sind kulturell mit den
russen verwandt wir dürfen uns nicht von
unseren brüdern und unseren starken
harmonischen mit großer dankbarkeit
verbunden
wir wollen ja auch gar nicht sagen ich
glaube das wird niemand am tisch dass
jetzt alle russen schulzen an diesem
krieg weil er diese haltung wie dna die
ist ja schon herausragend anders das
muss man einfach sagen erfordert auch
viel mut wir sagen das einfach so locker
hier aber was war wagenknecht was auch
sie wird der sarg ist ja nicht der
mainstream sondern jeder der eine solche
äußerung macht am tag wird ja beschossen
auf den sozialen netzwerken als putin
vorsteherin als russland freundin
gebrandmarkt und das muss man auch erst
mal aushalten deswegen
ebenso leder freien meinungsäußerung
respekt davor wenn sie frau bank nicht
sind ja heute noch ein bisschen weiter
gegangen und haben gemeinsam mit klaus
ernst gefordert das nord stream 2 wieder
angefahren wird dann geben wir so ein
bisschen drüber hinweg hier was zu einer
ja ich weiß nicht ob orten reaktion von
verschiedenen mitgliedern ihrer partei
ihrer fraktion geführt hat und bis in
solider fahrer empört reagiert mama der
gesagt hat das ist nicht die position
der linken also so ganz konkurrent ist
das auch innerhalb ihres politischen
lagers nicht ja ich kann das auch
erläutern also warum ich trotzdem zwei
überhaupt ins gespräch gebracht habe
also wenn wir jetzt sagen wir haben
keine anderen lieferanten oder es ist so
norwegen hat gesagt 2024 können sie mehr
liefern katar hat gesagt
2026 vielleicht und dann zu schlimmen
konditionen und selbst die us fracking
industrie hat auch also eigentlich klar
gemacht also kurzfristig gibt es da
nicht genug also haben wir nur die wahl
wir gehen sehenden auges in den
gas-notstand und würden unsere
wirtschaft ab und wir sitzen nimmt im
kalten oder wir kaufen russisches gas
und zwar so viel wie wir brauchen so und
dann gibt es ja bei dem einst ein
tatsächliches problem als natürlich hat
tut ihnen das jetzt politisch genutzt
und die lieferungen auch deshalb
reduziert weil er ja auf den
wirtschaftsweg reagiert aber es gibt ja
ein objektives problem das ist diese
turbine die das hat ja siemens auch
bestätigt in kanada gewartet wird ganz
regulär und die die aber nicht
zurückschicken weil das ja unter die
sanktionen fällt das heißt es von sieben
gesagt es geht auch ohne die turbinen
aber nicht mit voller leistung habe ich
also ich bin kein techniker ich weiß es
nicht auf jeden fall ist es glaube ich
schon so vielleicht hätten sie nicht auf
40 prozent reduzieren müssen vielleicht
hätten sie auch 60 liefern können aber
volle leistung bei nordstream 1 geht
zurzeit nicht dann gibt es noch eine
pipeline die geht durch polen die ist
sowieso interessant da haben wir früher
auch gas bekommen und jetzt ist es seit
weihnachten so dass deutschland polen
gas verkauft also unsere gasspeicher
werden ja voller wenn wir nicht seit
weihnachten die pipeline umgekehrt
beliefern wollen würden weil polen
wollte kein gas mehr aus russland
bezieht deswegen seither gas aus
deutschland russisches gas was wir über
nord stream 1 bekommen und sie sind
jetzt ganz unabhängig von russland aber
die gasspeicher in polen sind voll
unsere halt nicht das heißt die
jamal-pipeline so heißt sie die läuft
zurzeit auch nicht und dann ist nur noch
die pipeline durch die ukraine die geht
halt durch kriegsgebiet das heißt wenn
wir gas kaufen wollten brauchen wir
pipelines und die eine die note 2 liegt
halt da am boden ist fertig und könnte
theoretisch frei geschaltet werden also
mir geht es nicht um nord stream zwei
mir geht es darum dass wir irgendwie das
problem lösen müssen dass wir nicht im
herbst entweder industrieanlagen kaputt
machen die gehen ja nicht die die sind
ja dann hinüber also wenn die chemische
industrie nicht ausreichend gas hat sind
milliardenschwere anlagen im eimer oder
umgekehrt die haushalte auch nicht in
eine situation bringen dass plötzlich
der vermieter festlegen kann es wird nur
noch auf 16 oder 18 grad geheizt das
heißt ja jetzt im bundestag beschlossen
worden dass jetzt die regierung quasi
dekretieren kann haushalte werden nicht
mehr richtig geheizt oder warmem wasser
fließt nur noch zu wenigen tagen sind
sie politisch doch so erfahren und auf
der einen und und und und erwägen hier
erwecken den eindruck das wäre alles
ganz einfach wenn er aber nur über
seinen energiepolitischen schatten und
frau berbalk über ihre humanistische
außenpolitik richtig aber mit großen
anfangs bringen würden und sagen würde
komm zu uns an den tisch machen wir sind
doch eingebunden in das nato system die
sich alle zuletzt vor einer woche stein
und bein geschworen haben diesen
aggressor in sich entgegen system da ist
es doch völlig undenkbar dass wir ein
alleingang machten aber andere machen
das auch die türkei macht einen tollen
alleingang dieser beteiligt sich
komplett nicht an den sanktionen
da sind zwei pipelines die in die türkei
gehen diesen voll ausgelastet und
dadurch das vermeintlich auch hierfür
sind türkei als vorbild nehmen auch
ungarn beteiligt sich nicht an den
sanktionen also es gibt eine reihe von
ländern die sich nicht an den sanktionen
teiligen und mir egal was die türkei
macht und was bürgern manchmal möchte
dass wir unser land nicht ruinieren oder
genau und wie es geht ist auch für
unsere pflicht als deutsche dass wir
weil wir klein sind und weil wir ja
komplett abhängig sind von der usa dir
als nato-chef über unsere aussenpolitik
und sicherheitspolitik bestimmen dass
wir die beeinflussen das und das tut ja
der kanzler auch und das tut ja auch die
verteidigungsministerin und da wäre mein
plädoyer an die medien dass sie bitte
den bundeskanzler und und diese die
leute die sich ein bisschen auch
besonnen zeigen und nicht blatak taschen
sind sondern dass sie ein bisschen
zurückreisen plappert asche viele
politiker da wollen wir jetzt keinen da
müssen sie jetzt
das problem ist dass die die medien
treiben die politiker vor sich her die
politiker sind darauf angewiesen gewählt
zu werden und sie glauben dass das was
in der zeitung steht der wille des
volkes ist und damit setzen sie diese
leute in die falsche richtung ich habe
es so geschätzt dass die
verteidigungsministerin helme geschickt
hat dafür hätte er einen orden
ja man hätte einer norden geben will
die idee mit dem namen besser aber das
darf nicht gemeinsam aber
sie sagt erhält mehr geht nicht dann
heißt es schwitzen mehr geht nicht aus
dann heißt es der gepard mehr geht nicht
und jede woche heißt dass irgendwas
kommt hinterher mehr geht nicht das ist
natürlich keine glauben wissen wir heute
sagen wir hätten wir gerne eine zu ihrer
these nein sehr lebendig heute ich liebe
das wir alle thesen müssen drankommen